YEN-JIE LEE: I think for
the physics educators,
I would suggest
then to introduce
the kind of big
question we are trying
to solve in the very
beginning of the lecture.
Then people will come
into your lecture
and then knowing that
we are trying to solve
this specific question.
Then we work on the theoretical
calculation using our physics
intuition and physical laws
we learned from other class
to solve this question.
And then we check
if we have answered
the big question
which we actually
introduced in the beginning.
And finally, I
would like to stress
that comparison between,
say, analytical calculation
and the demo is actually
very, very important.
OK?
Because that gives
you a chance to verify
your theoretical assumption
to see if our calculations
actually make any sense.
And finally, I usually summarize
the kind of take-home message,
or the conclusion
from this course
so that people can walk
out of the classroom
and knowing that
this is actually what
they learned from this lecture.
So actually, I think
that is actually
a applicable to all kinds
of different physics course.
If we actually try
to do that way,
then that would make the physics
course much more enjoyable.
In general, teaching
a course, the lecturer
has to show that he is so
interested in this course.
It is true when the lecturer
actually knows about the course
very well and knows the
excitement about this course
very well.
So why don't you just show it?
Right?
Because that will
excite a lot of interest
from the students
in the classroom.
And also, that will make your
lecture much more enjoyable,
not only for the students,
but also for yourself
because you feel really
happy when you're
teaching in the classroom.